you went to Starfield what is Starfield
and what's the origin story of this game
we had always wanted to do
something where you explore space you
know the explore space role-playing game
so take the kind of games that we make
and
give it a little bit of a different Spin
and
you know the other games that I loved
there was a pen and paper RPG I love
traveler it was one of the first games I
made for the Apple II
I didn't uh I never finished it right
I'm just doing it on my own
and I love this game starflight was one
star control two was a game that I loved
um Sundog was a big one in the Apple two
days that a lot of people don't know
that I loved and so a lot of us in the
studio felt it was time to do something
new you know we're going between Elder
Scrolls and Fallout and going back and
forth and I mean we love that but hey
we've always wanted to do this explore
the Galaxy science fiction game
you know now is the time uh to do that
and uh that's a brave move so follow-ups
post-op apocalyptic
on a single Planet
uh you know Elder Scrolls series is
uh on a single planet so this is going
out into the open world of many Star
systems many planets I saw that it's uh
thinking about a hundred star systems in
a thousand planets available to explore
um what is that world of stars and
planets like
well you mentioned Daggerfall we go back
to some of that well the first one we
did it was how are we gonna
render a planet like pull it off for the
player like can we
or do we have to sort of do it where you
can't land on all of them where you're
Landing in a very controlled small world
space that we you know kind of craft and
you would have a very limited set of
those if you go back to tone like well
that's probably the wrong tone
and how can we say yes like I want to
land on that ice ball so it started we
started the game right after Fallout 4
so 2016.
and the first thing we did was can you
know how can we have a system to
generate these planets and make them
look
you know I'll say reasonable as opposed
to you know fractally goop
um you know what's the what's the
technical definition of goop fractally
practically goop you've probably seen a
lot of like simulations whether they're
space things or landscape things where
they're using fractals and just the
landscape does not look real just this
is like highs and lows and it's muddy
and so we did find a way we came up with
a way had prototyped of of building
tiles like large tiles of landscape the
way we would usually build them we kind
of generate them offline hand do some
things and end up with these very
realistic looking tiles of landscape and
then built a system that wraps those
around a planet and blends them all
together
and we had pretty successful results
with that and so we thought yeah we
could we could do this
um and so there was a big design
kind of problem to solve in terms of
what's fun
about landing on a planet where there's
potentially nothing
because there's a lot of planets and
moons if you kind of write in reality
that well there's nothing on them except
resources and so we spent a lot of time
figuring out okay let's just lean in on
that can a be a lonely experience as
long as we tell the player here's what's
there here are the resources that are
there go find them but I equate it to
that moment of we said about listening
to the wind go and watching the sunset
and I do think there's a certain Beauty
to landing on a strange Planet being
somewhat the only person there building
an outpost and we are modeling
all of the systems because that's how we
like to do things so you can watch
whatever that gas giant or Moon it will
rotate and go and
Sunrise Sunset and all of those things
that you would expect and it's it's all
really happening and most people
probably won't notice or appreciate all
of that but
um
I think it gives them the ability to say
I want to go do that and see that on
that place as long as we tell them hey
the quest leads over here here's where
the handcrafted content is that you
would expect and then here's more of the
open procedural
Planet experience so your long answer I
don't know if I answered your question
there's no all right questions as stupid
and the answers are brilliant so that's
how this works so this is the world's
most immense simulator of um The Human
Condition of loneliness
because I can't imagine a more lonely
experience I mean you put it that way I
don't know that was the goal but just on
a planet alone I just
that must be
I mean just a deep embodiment of what
loneliness is like
I mean both on like when you hike alone
there's a there's a deep loneliness to
that it's like uh it's humbling that
this thing will last much longer than
you it's been here way before you
is it the line from the moon landing
beautiful desolation
it's Buzz Aldrin is it beautiful
desolation is that what you said I think
so beautiful desolation well something
like that but that's just words there's
a feeling to it and you want that
feeling to be real
you just hear there's some resources
here I just feel like it will hit people
at a certain moment like it does for me
with Skyrim like
holy [ __ ] I'm here alone
and then and whatever cruel nature
that's out there it doesn't really care
about me
exactly Dusty that's that's the
experience so you you want to create the
whole planet and you want to have many
of them
we have we do have many but once you
build that system I think the numbers
become
I mean honestly a little bit we we wrap
it in so we can name them all and and
have a finite set even though it's a
very very large number but a set that we
can
you know validate and and know about
even though it's a huge number but once
you
once you're Building A system that can
build a planet I mean a planet is sort
of Infinite Space we go back to the
Daggerfall analogy right
if you have systems to build that much
space doing 100 plants or a thousand or
ten thousand or a million planets it's
not it's just you just press you just
change the number and press the button
but you can't you can't name them all
you can't control like when you're
getting in really big numbers
hey what is what does this system way
out here feel like if you take your ship
and jump that far
we do level the systems when you go to
system you'll see oh this is like a
level 40 system and us being able to at
least control that scale is how we kind
of ended up with the 100-ish systems we
have what are the what are the levelings
what do you mean by level levels it
could be like when you look at a map in
a game it says this is the area for
low-level players this is level one oh
God yeah yeah so we do that on a system
basis
star system
I read that space travel is considered
dangerous in this game can you explain
that's more of us back to a tone thing
right when you actually play the game
because it's a game like we don't really
kill you when you fly out in space but
it has a tone of there's some effort
involved
and we've dialed it back as we've been
making the game whereas we used to run
out of fuel you jump and get stranded
which on paper was a great like it's a
great moment when you get stranded you
have to press this Beacon you don't know
who's going to come
um turns out that's not like it just
stops your game we found you'll be
playing the game and I ran out of fuel
okay I guess I'll just
wander these planets trying to mine for
fuel so I can get back to what I was
doing it just you know it's a fun killer
that's too realistic of a simulation of
The Human Condition
yeah I know the idea was well it's very
you know games do that if you had like a
hardcore you're right a hardcore
survival mode that's the kind of thing
you would do maybe we'll do it in the
future
um but it's more of like a tone how they
build their ships do they have all the
right things for safety
um we do get into environmental things
on the planets you know in your space
suit obviously a lot of different
spacesuits and Buffs for you know the
gases the toxicity or the temperature on
on various planets
are there robots yes those companions
are they robots by chance can you one of
the companions the robot Vasco yeah okay
so they have they have uh they have a
name and a personality and so on and
Vasco does and then there's a whole
bunch of I call them generic robots
they're you like we use them for utility
you know okay people we actually dialed
them back because if you think about
well you know a lot about this more than
uh me in terms of I'm offended right now
you're calling robots generic no no the
ones we use the ones we we use we made
them more generic we didn't so we didn't
feel very sensitive about this I
understand
um if you were to chart the future you
would say robots would have a much
bigger role in our future than we are
presenting
um but that was a tone thing so we most
of our robots are there as utility
robots and there are some combat ones as
well as enemies so it's a deeply human
world very much yes in in terms of its
own
uh so
have you talked to Elon about this about
this game over there a little bit
how much of reality like the work of
SpaceX is an inspiration for the
decisions made in this game
I wouldn't say it's for the decisions we
made but
you know visiting SpaceX and walking in
there it was
it's like the Avengers meech NASA it's
like the most amazing and here we're
building the next gen like see the the
dragon stuff before it was uh you know
other people saw it like just I was
really
in awe
you know this giant machine that looks
for imperfections on the surface of
these giant
you know fuselah just you know whenever
and because you know we're in DC go to
the air and space museum a lot and so
whenever I look at those kind of things
or you know you'll visit the space
shuttle sort of overcome with how big it
is and I go stand back by the engines
and think about that thing leaving orbit
you know and one of the things that Elon
really impresses like we're reaching the
edge of physics on a lot of the stuff
where how hard it is
to leave
orbit
the gravitational pull and like so the
engineering that has gone into that
rspace program what what he's doing now
um I just marvel at I don't understand
oh right I'm not at that level but I
Marvel at the kind of human Ingenuity
and scale
I was
on the Delaware Coast last month
and I went I was outside I was outside
for some reason it was dark and I saw
this crazy light in the sky
and I thought it was like a helicopter
and then it didn't go away
and I'm like someone what is that I call
my we had with some friends hey does
everybody see this what is that and we
just stood dumbfounded looking at this
thing in the sky
and
like that is a UFO nobody takes their
phone out everyone I'm with like four
people everyone is too dumbstruck you
would think why don't you take a picture
of this thing
and the next day we found out it was in
the news it was the SpaceX launch in
Florida
and I'm seeing it from
Delaware Maryland area it was one of the
most it was incredible it's just even
just that
I am in complete awe is there some
aspect to that that you can replicate
the The Majestic nature that in in the
video game
the answer to that you know I think some
of it we
were doing when you're standing on a
planet and you see you see the other
moons go by yeah and then you realize I
could get my ship blast off and land
there and build myself a home I think
that's pretty cool
there's a minor thing we do which is we
um we have other ships come and go from
the Star ports when you're there so
you'll be in a city and then you hear
this when you hear the engine you look
up and the ship is taking off or come
out that's great there's nothing for you
to do but
it's I think it's awesome yeah yeah
and then that's all about creating the
soundscape to feel
seeing it and like oh that's real that's
a ship that or you jump into a system
and you see these Freighters and
sometimes they contact you like
um it's not all just like jump in and
combat
do you ever think about the fact that
science fiction seems to make a
it has a way of creating reality
not just kind of predicting it or
imagining it it's almost like the thing
you put out there with a video game like
this
like Starfield that you kind of
anticipate
it it kind of fuels people's imagination
of what is possible
maybe I don't know I don't know I can't
I can't say you're making me think now
about other science fiction that
movie I love Minority Report it's more
of like a not a space movie but more
like looking at the future if you look
at a lot of the things in that movie
it's almost like I think those are
coming true yeah I mean uh is that the
one that you do interface this like uh
it's the interfaces and then the you
know he looks his child's more like a
holographic almost AR VR kind of thing
or digital billboards
or trying to predict human behavior
um there's a there's just a lot of
future stuff in that movie as it comes
to sci-fi to your other question I don't
know I I don't know
well I think it does and it's
interesting I mean I suppose
you're trying to create the most realist
sticking to the tone the most immersive
realistic world and almost by accident
you create the thing that is possible
because you want it to be realistic in
some deep sense so
accidentally can become the possible and
then that places that idea in people's
heads I mean if humans are ever to
become a multi-planetary species
we need
we need to play games
we need to read sci-fi to help imagine
that that's possible to look outside of
Earth to look outside look up on the
stars then we can actually travel out
there I don't know there's power to
sci-fi to do that I guess you shouldn't
feel the pressure of that foreign
now that's all that what we're doing
might now maybe you know
one of our you know hopefully it might
Inspire some young people who are headed
in that direction alike
Oh I thought about getting into space
and space exploration and being an
engineer doing these things and I played
this game and
you know it really
sparked that interest in me so I'm gonna
go take that as a field and maybe that's
the person who goes and does some of
these things yeah because in the next
couple of decades
a likely a human being will step foot on
Mars which are the first steps towards
us becoming multi-planetary
and if you read some of the stuff
they're doing uh with the James Webb
Telescope and them being able to look
for signs of life
on other planets it's quite fascinating
and you know recent stuff I read say
they think in 20 years they will
so
it's actually quite encouraging to think
I've almost dream of mine like in our
lifetimes that we discover Life on
another planet
yeah especially if it's intelligent life
I've been talking to a lot of biologists
and a lot of folks I imagine there's
life everywhere out there the numbers
are would say so yes the challenging
question is what it looks like and how
much of it is intelligent so a lot of
biologists tell me the big the big
difficult leap is from the precarious to
the eukaryotes so like the the complex
life it could be that a lot of our
universe is just filled with bacteria
I believe if if I'm understanding it
right that there's two ways they're
going to look at planets when they can
look at you know they can read hey this
planet has this kind of gas they can now
look at the ones that are created by
potential life forms and then the ones
that are created the byproducts of
Industry so there's only certain ones
that are created if you have a society
there
um and that they can start looking on
these types of in these types of star
systems and these planets but it takes a
lot of time because you have to book
time in that telescope you have to like
look at that planet over a long period
of time but
in theory given enough time given the
amount of space out there
um
we would find one
that would be a cool thing in this short
life of ours to find out
definitively that there is an an
industrial intelligent civilization out
there
before you contact them so like die end
your life
not knowing the rest of the story but
just know that it's out there that's a
cool and then if you have kids be like
well this one's on you
uh F this I'm out and I'm fascinated by
what it would do
to the way I think in a positive way the
way Humanity thinks about itself here
like no there's there is a definitively
other life out there I mean both things
if there isn't life out there
that's also a huge responsibility both
are super exciting
for a loan it's super exciting because
there's a responsibility to preserve
whatever special thing we have going on
here this um
whether you call it the flame of
Consciousness or whether it's
Consciousness or intelligence that's the
special thing preserve it have it expand
but if there's others out there
I mean that like that Sparks that drive
for exploration
of reaching out to the stars and meeting
them
most of them probably want to kill us
so but luckily we have the
military-industrial complex on Earth
that builds bigger and better weapons
all the time space force it will both
protect us and destroy all our enemies
[Laughter]
uh uh this this is 100 a video game
we're living in